[Musique]
et bonjour la saignée alizés le
département signe aujourd'hui avec cinq
entreprises les premières conventions du
nouveau dispositif passe bien être une
aide accordée par la collectivité pour
soutenir les personnes âgées les
bénéficiaires des minima sociaux
touché par la crise ducobu de 19 waouh
pouvoir ben senti un peu de cet état de
crise psychologique et bien prendre un
peu soin de soi même en allant vers des
entreprises de tous les secteurs du
bien-être à le sport les loisirs la
culture impasse d'une valeur de 150
euros sera disponible à plus de 130
mille bénéficiaires
un dispositif qui accompagne également
les petites et moyennes entreprises dans
la relance de l'activité économique
aux entreprises de relancer un peu leurs
activités mais ce qui est important
aussi la danse sera permettre aux
familles les plus modestes de résister à
des activités de loisirs de culture
l'accompagnement social du département
se traduit également par le lancement du
chèque d'accompagnement personnalisé
alimentaires et d'hygiène
une aide dont le montant varie entre 70
et 200 euros pour effectuer des achats
de première nécessité quand vous avez
par exemple des papas et des mamans qui
ont déjà des enfants bas dans
l'accompagnement des montagnes afin par
exemple des couches bébé il n'y a pas de
lait pour les enfants et c'est pour cela
que nous avons développé ce chèque
d'accompagnement personnalisé qui va
permettre aux familles les plus en
difficulté de pouvoir acheter ce dont
elles ont besoin
ces deux dispositifs dead sont inscrits
dans le plan départemental de relance
économique et sociale votée par la
collectivité pour surmonter les
conséquences de l'épidémie de kobe 19
sur les 570 millions de budget alloué
plus de 20 millions viendront soutenir
les personnes fragiles et vulnérables
[Musique]